we got the story from Fox News how dare
you mother of two sons who died from
fentanyl demands Biden apologized for
laughing about her story don't be a
coward do something kiesling said in
response to President Biden so here's
the story
this woman had two of her sons die in in
summer of 2020. they took some pills
they thought were Percocet they were
laced with fentanyl they died she's very
upset about it and the drugs apparently
came over the southern border a problem
for which Donald Trump was trying to
solve and actually campaigned on solving
in 2015 a problem that existed under the
Biden uh of the Obama Biden
Administration
so Marjory Taylor green interviews this
woman Marjorie Taylor green then tweets
out basically Biden's policies resulted
in this and like these people died and
then Biden when asked about it starts
laughing saying that was under the other
guy that was that was under the Trump
Administration
so she's pissed obviously her kids are
dead and the important point in this
whole story is that Donald Trump
inherits Joe Biden's administrator it's
Obama's administration but Biden's the
VP
trumpet at his campaigning in 2015 like
we got to secure the Border we got to
stop the drug cartels what happens the
media calls him racist
okay Biden the Biden Administration
comes back in after the fact the Border
collapses they they claimed When Donald
Trump was desperately trying to get
funding to build the wall that he was
racist and they shouldn't do it it
wouldn't work anyway
so here you have Joe Biden laughing that
these two kids who died died while Trump
was President despite the fact that
Trump was trying to fix the problem so I
imagine it like this Joe Biden and
Barack Obama are in charge of the fire
department when a bunch of fires erupt
and they don't do anything about it and
then Donald Trump says give me the
firehouse and I'll put the fire out
Trump then starts desperately spraying
these buildings trying to stop the fire
and then after a few years Biden comes
back takes it from him and then laughs
at all people who died in that fire yeah
they were like are you anti-fire Donald
are you you fire phobic
yes I guess they said when when Trump is
like China's sending drugs they're like
you can't say that that's racist then
these kids die and Biden's like haha
that was Trump is there video of him
laughing oh yeah yeah he was giving a
speech uh
he was laughing in a malicious way he's
just not present of mine yeah he's doing
he wasn't necessarily laughing at the
woman he was laughing and mocking
Marjorie Taylor green but it's like the
context of it is Marjorie Taylor green
says these two young men died because of
these border policies and it's Biden's
fault and Biden's like no it wasn't
Trump was President it's like dude you
were the vice president before Trump got
in and Trump literally campaigned on
stopping a problem that was happening
under your Administration how can you
how do you blame Trump for that he
doesn't understand because Hunter knew
where to get the clean ones that's right
yeah he's got connections I think the
Democrats
are the party of short-term gains so
they will let the Border crisis keep
going if it gives them a short-term
benefit in terms of economic you know
but then he gives his State of the Union
Address and says well we got to fix the
crisis at the border we had over 70 000
fentanyl deaths
as if he actually cares when they're the
ones creating this problem and throwing
gasoline on the dumpster fire at the
border but he did say that at the state
of the union he pretended to care at
least for a moment can we just can I
just you know someone else wrote that
though Joe Biden so
Joe Biden laughs at the story and it's
just it was a layup it was so easy
someone could have come to him and said
we got a really really great opportunity
to boost your approval rating it's
really really great this this Marjorie
Taylor green is talking to this mother
whose children died he's the Border
crisis there's a perfect opportunity for
you to win some points all you got to do
is say
I'm so sorry to hear about what happened
to your children trust me when I say I
will do whatever it takes to seek
Justice and make sure we end the
fentanyl crisis we are working very hard
I'm sorry we let you down but trust me
we'll get the job done couldn't he just
do that like does he have anybody you
don't even have to mean it no I know
that's what I'm saying like just just
give us some empty platitudes about
trust me we're working hard no he left I
don't even need a plan nothing but look
look here's a guy who took a secret trip
to Ukraine with half a billion dollars
while the East Palestine crisis was
happening and there's toxic chemicals
spilling and he's just like well better
go to Ukraine that's that's what matters
you know to me I guess so I'm just kind
of bummed yeah I want to insult him
yeah I don't think it's an insult
he's a bit of a prick I'm gonna call him
um a dismissive prick is what I want to
call him but like I've seen him just be
like laugh and dismiss people like ah
come on Matt Walsh would be proud uh and
like he just laughed and did the whole
dismissive thing on Marjorie which is
what this sounds like because like
that's the laughing and dismissal kind
of thing though I've seen him do it to
people that are like hey like people his
constituents yelling at him when he was
on the campaign Trail I remember him get
up in a guy's face one time he called
him fat didn't he and he challenged him
to a push-up contest wait who Joe Biden
yeah he challenged him to a push-up
contest he got in that guys you know
what's he called him fat you know what's
funny is that Trump's actually been
doing better at you know one of the
things about Trump that's I know a lot
of people liked but a lot of people who
voted for him really didn't like was his
Brash attitude he was he was divisive
you know he he'd call people names he'd
insult them now what are we seeing from
Trump he's putting out videos that are
just like straightforward policy
corporate press is calling it a
traditional campaign or more so a
traditional campaign and Joe Biden is
just laughing about these problems like
he's not even he's not even planning on
running anyway maybe that's really it
maybe he's just saying he's gonna run
but he knows he's not even care what's
incredible too is they they had they
give Marjorie so much crap for how she
acted at the State of the Union because
she called him a liar
but now he laughs in the face of this
mother whose two kids died
and silence except from Fox News he
laughs uh Hillary Clinton laughs
wickedly Kamala Harris laughs like an
idiot like like Hillary Clinton laughs
wickedly because she's wicked Joe Biden
laughs because he is demented and none
of those laughs are because there's a
big difference like it's none of it's
because like a joke was told and they're
laughing in response like oh my gosh
is the most witchy laugh I've ever heard
it starts off deep did you see the girl
did the uh the Kamala Harris impression
she's like no no it starts off deep
just think of us the psychological
makeup of a career prosecutor it's like
no eight years isn't enough they're all
in for 30. to beat have that amount of
power right now and to be laughing about
stuff is insane to me I I understand
humor we're human it's part of what we
are but like I think they're laughing
because they have no vision of of how to
solve these problems so they're just I
think we should just accept it though
that's who they are they're laughing at
us they're laughing at us while we die
because of problems they created
one more time oh I said they're laughing
at us and that's we should just accept
it this is who they are they're laughing
at us while our children die because of
problems they created yep but while
they're laughing at us they're also
turning around and going these poor
people in Ukraine don't you care about
the ukrainians and I'm like I I mean
personally I'm so disconnected from what
matters to normal people I mean yes
they're emotionally attached to people
in a country they can't find on a map
but their own country they just don't
care about is this the most morally
obvious thing to take a stand on I think
it's lowest effort different than that
though you said they're disconnected I
don't think they're disconnected at all
they know people are starving they know
people can't afford to eat they can't
afford to live here and they're choosing
to care about these other things they're
choosing to laugh in the face they know
all these things but they're not
personally connected to it like I
remember there was this um Professor
from like Colombia or something who
years ago published a book about how
he's like a functional oh my mic is
popping he's like a functional heroine
user and he's he's not an addict he's
just a user but um he's obviously like
you know not connected to the experience
of people who in the opioid crisis are
on these drugs because uh you know
they're on the track to a death of
Despair and he's also sourcing his
heroin like in a way that's safe because
of his socioeconomic status
and uh then he publishes a book that
completely downplays the gravity of this
crisis because he's not really a part of
it you know
and he's also a libertine like a moral
academic so he doesn't have any morals I
don't remember what his name was he was
just some like Professor
um wrote a book that was basically about
like uh how he thinks that harm
reduction is uh the best solution to the
opioid crisis but also like you can use
uh drugs like you can use narcotics
safely uh if you don't have like
pre-existing mental conditions which is
he basically denied that
that opiates have a pharmacological uh
element of like addictiveness which is
obviously untrue so the doctor with the
dreadlocks call something yeah I don't
remember I never saw a picture of him I
just uh heard about it that's why top
down governance doesn't work why central
planning doesn't work because you get
you lose touch with the people that
you're not around you need to let them
govern themselves from a distance you
have to I that's a mix man there's got
to be some plan for like National
Defense like the original idea of
federalism you know there's a federal
government but it's fairly weak in the
states mostly take care of their own
business the problem is as a culture
we're just too different
I suppose if you go back to the the
foundings of this country most people
just want to be left alone and that
worked really well like if you're in you
know a new state or whatever you're like
look I'm here I'm doing my thing leave
me alone the problem now is you have
authoritarian ideologues in places like
California that want authority over
Texas and New York or you know New York
and California basically agree on the
same things so they want authority over
Texas and Florida so Texas and Florida
can sit there all day and night and be
like we we hereby agree to be left alone
and we'll leave you alone and California
goes you got it buddy and then as soon
as they turn around they go start
screwing with them so I I don't know how
you we we I don't know if there's a
classical liberal solution to the
problem we're facing right in times of
War
like I'll put it this way Anarchist
societies don't work right we can talk
about I think Catalonia the famous
Anarchist attempt at a country I forgot
what the story was but they try to
create this Anarchist enclave and it
gets crushed instantly by barbaric
outside forces if you've got a hundred
you know Guild members who vote on
policy because that's an anarchist
system everybody comes together and they
wiggle their fingers and then next door
you've got an authoritarian regime where
one guy dictates everything what do you
think is going to happen the one guy
dictating everything is going to say to
his his military crush them and then
when the anarchist people see The
Barbarians heading towards the city they
go we're under attack quick what do we
do and they're like well we're
anarchists we don't believe in
centralized planning so let's hold a
meeting and have a discussion on how do
we approach this this attack and then a
day later they're overrun and they're
all dead
you know you could have some kind of
mixed system where in times of emergency
they elect an Executor who can then take
over and become a temporary Emperor like
we saw with I think it was Cincinnatus
was was that yeah he was like right he's
like I don't want to be an emperor and
they're like well we're in an emergency
and we need one now to act with
executive you know emergency powers and
then after like what like two weeks he
was like I'm a farmer again I don't want
to do this and it's like it's like an
epic story but the issue is in times of
Crisis and emergency we fall into
executive decision making we don't just
sit back and say let's vote on it so
right now as we're dealing with a cult
ideological authoritarian authoritarian
and terroristic regime there is no
passive voting your way out of a
conflict with these people
they're firebombing buildings they're
sterilizing kids vote like there there
is no peaceful let's all come together
and have a decision no it's going to be
for now I think the solution is probably
hard legislation and law enforcement no
more you know we got to be we got to be
tolerant of the adult man thrusting his
hips in front of that baby no that's a
crime and that person should probably be
arrested in charge and it's about time
we stop passively saying we'll just let
them do their thing because it doesn't
bother us hey look we're here in Texas
and in Texas we have laws but if
California wants to do it that's
California's business that's federalism
and that's what people are arguing for
and I'm kind of like nah maybe the
federal government should be like
there's a standard and you can't have
sex adult sex shows for children so
we're going to stop that but but too
many conservatives are telling me that
Civil War is not gonna it can't happen
the country would be crushed China would
take over fair point I agree and then
they say Federalism is the answer let
the states do what they want and I'm
like why so California can start having
sex shows for kids like they've been
doing that they're doing it in Texas I
don't see a classical liberal solution
to this there's going to have to be a a
centralized Baseline morality that we
all agree on so and then we enforce the
law and we're seeing it in California
now with the gender transition stuff
making that a safe haven for kids to go
to California so if you can't get it in
Texas you can go over to California and
get like abortion right thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time